- Let's get to our first guest though.
He is very funny, very
talented. I love him so much.
I do think he stole a guitar off the wall
the last time he was at our show.
So he's a kleptomaniac. It's fine.
His new podcast is called Black Box.
You can listen on Apple, Spotify,
and wherever you get your podcasts.
Give it up for Joel McHale!
Oh my gosh!
- Hello!
Come on, guys.
- [Kelly] Oh, they are adorable!
- [Joel] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- Oh, come on, come on.
There we go, you're okay. You're okay.
- [Kelly] He's like,
the stairs are freaky...
There you go!
- [Joel] There we go.
Come on.
Come on, guys, let's go!
- Oh my gosh, you brought pigs!
- These are for you!
- Come on over!
Oh, can I feed? I want... Can I feed?
- Yeah, you want to feed 'em?
- Yes!
- I hope this works.
- Okay. Okay.
- Their names of Spiderman and MJ.
- Oh my God. I love it.
Do you want some?
- And I just named them ten seconds ago.
There you go.
You just stay there.
- You want it?
- There we are.
- It's everywhere, but it's okay.
Do I know how to do this?
- [Joel] You're doing great.
You clearly have done this with babies,
where you dangle the bottle over them.
- [Kelly] I'm trying.
- [Joel] It makes them want it.
- [Kelly] I'm trying so hard.
- Do it!
I'm failing, you try.
- [Joel] Well, it's matcha,
so I don't know if...
- Oh!
- There you go, bud.
Yeah.
Where are you going?
- [Kelly] Where are you going?
(Kelly chuckles)
- Kelly, my goal is
for you to never ask me
a single question...
- (Kelly laughs)
- That you'll just be completely
distracted the entire time.
- I never knew I wanted a little pig.
- [Joel] Well, the good news is,
in about two years, there'll
be 600 pounds a piece.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- So that's a fun, fun
animal to have in your home.
- I've actually had pigs before in Texas.
- Really?
- Yeah, but they were
like on our rescue farm,
so they were a pet, but we rescued them.
I didn't have them from like a piglet.
- You didn't raise them.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I couldn't think of the word. Thank you.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Joel] No, no, it's...
- Raise them!
- See, I do raise pigs for a living.
- [Kelly] You do?
- Yeah
- [Kelly] You do so much, Joel.